[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا رامي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل الزوايا هو من
جميع الجوانب
روسيا بوضع صعب ويعلن غدا اهدافه العسكريه
للعمل المقبل
بيتشكو مسيره
ايراني حاليا
امام القضاء ويقر بمسؤوليته عن انقلاب عام
وفي القضايا الرياضيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتابعون ايضا
بعد خروجه من المربع الذهبي في كاس العالم
المنتخب المغربي يصل الرباط باستقبال
الحفل
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الى هذه الصور ونبدا فيها هذه
النشره
للملك ملك المغرب محمد السادس وهو يقلد
لاعبي المنتخب المغربي الذين
يشاركون في هذا تكريم الرسمي
بوجود امهاتهم
اذا هذا التكريم ياتي بعد الفوز التاريخي
والنتائج التاريخيه
للمنتخب المغربي الذي حققه في
مونديال قطر 2022
طبعا سبق هذا التكريم الرسمي احتفال كبير
اسود الاطلس في العاصمه المغربيه الرباط
منتخب القوي المتماسك حقق فوزا كان حلما
صار حقيقه مباشره على الباب نحو عطاتنا
قبل يوم احلام مراه
يعني التي ااا يعني كل المغرب طبعا فرح
بمشاهدتها وكذلك العرب والعالم يعني كلنا
تاثرنا عندما كان اا يحقق اي لاعب هدفا في
مرمى الفريق المنافس يذهب بسرعه لاحتضان
لوالدته وها هي الامهات الى جانب ابنائهم
في هذا التكريم الكبير الذي
يقوم به الملك محمد السادس ويقلد فيه كل
لاعب
ميداليه نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
زكريا ابو خلال
دفتر وان وصلت الى الشباك الخصم وحققت
الهدف فالعود والمسير من جديد
وسام العرش درجه ضابط
سليم املاح شغف قوي بالقميص الوطني واراده
تتحدث الصعاب لتشريفه وشرفنائه
[موسيقى]
يوما بعد يوم تغوص القوات الروسيه اكثر في
المستنقع الاوكراني دخلت موسكو الى الشرق
الاوكراني لكن الرهانه اصبح بالبقاء وسط
التقدم تاره وتراجع تاره اخرى اعلن الكرام
لان الرئيس الروسي سيحدد غدا اهداف جيشه
للعام 2013 خلال اجتماعا مع كبار القاده
العسكريين وقال الكلام لان بوتا سيعقدوا
اجتماعا الموسعا لوزاره الدفاع سيتم عرض
نتائج انشطه القوات المسلحه الروسيه في
عام 2022
وسيتم تحديد المهمات للعامل المقبل
بينما كان بوتا يزور خليفه
يزور جنوده على اخطر جبهات القتال
المستعار في اوكرانيا اختلاف الرسائل
والقوه في حرب لا يعرف احد حتى الان كيف
ومتى واين ستنتهي بالامس زارا بوتن
بيلاروسيا واجره محدثات مع نظيره وحليفه
الكسندر لوكي
يشارك الجيش الروسي في مناورات تكتيكيه
هناك اكيد ان الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حالته اقر بوتن ان الوضع صعب جدا في
المناطق الاربعه في جنوب وشرق اوكرانيا
التي اعلنت موسكو ضمها دون سيطره عليها
بالكامل
وفي دنيا اسكندريه اسكندريه
بشده وتحديد هويه الخونه والجواسيس
والمخربين بشكل انفعال
استغفر الله
روسيا تواجه اليوم تحديات كبيره وصعبه
تمسوا سيادتها ويجب التصدي لها لذلك روسيا
ممتنه لكل الجنود والضباط الذين اظهروا
شجاعه استثنائيه للدفاع عن وطنهم واداء
واجبهم العسكري في العمليه الخاصه ذلك
الواجب سيساعد في اقامه حياه طبيعيه
وسليمه للمواطنين في المناطق الجديده من
روسيا
كانت الزياره مختلفه فزياره بوتن تسرب على
انها استعداد لدخول بلا روسيا للحرب الى
جانب موسكو بينما في اوكرانيا زار الرئيس
بول
ساخنه شرق البلاد لدعم جنود بلاده المكتب
الاعلامي للرئاسه الاوكرانيه اكتفى بالقول
الناس التقى عسكريين وتحدث اليهم وقلد
الجنود او سببه الرجل وان كان يزور
بانتظام مناطق تقع قرب خط الجبهه الا ان
نتوجهها الى بخموت في منطقه دون بس ينطوي
على خطوره هي الاكبر زياره علق عليها نائب
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ميخائيله فيدوروف
عبر التلغرام بالقول نازل نسكي في بخمته
الرئيس الاكثر شجاعه للامه للاكثر شجاعه
[موسيقى]
واعمل موسكو ينضم الينا الكاتب السياسي
بسام البني اهلا بك معنا سيد بسام يعني
بوتين اقر بصراحه روسيا الان بوضع صعب
وعليه سيقوم غدا باعلان عن استراتيجيه
عسكريه جديده ما توقعك لملامح هذه
الاستراتيجيه ما هي الاهداف المتوسطه
المداح
قناه العربيه الكرام
لم يقصد ان القوات الروسيه في وضع صعب مع
اشار به بوتين هو يتعلق بموضوع صعوبه
العيش بالنسبه لسكان المناطق الاربعه
والحياه اليوميه وهمم وما يتعرضون له من
قصف ولذلك قال ان اا هذا الشعب يعول عليكم
كقوات مسلحه انا باعتقاد الشخصي غدا سيكون
هناك همم تصريحات حول موضوع يعني ضبط
الساعات الصحه التعبير بين القياد السياسي
والعسكريه في ظل التهديدات التي يتعرض لها
الامن الاستراتيجي الروسي وسيتعرض لما
سيختم القيام به من تزويد من اسلحه متطوره
للجيش الروسي خلال سنه 2023 اضيف الى ذلك
همم سيطرح
الشيبه يعني الوزير الدفاع همم تقريره
رئيس بوتر كقائد عامل القوات المسلحه عما
تم تنفيذه خلال عام 2022 انا برايي سننت-
سننتظر غدا نتائج واشارات واضحه الى
الضمانات الاجتماعيه لمشاركين في العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه كجنود وسلبات وصف ضباط
اضف الى ذلك الى اشاره الى تحقيق اهميه
تحقيق الاهداف العسكريه التي اعلنت من قبل
البوتين في عام في بدايه العمليه العسكريه
زياره الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى
بيلاروسيا في هذا التوقيت بالذات همم قد
تنطوي على مخاطر من هجوم جديد قد ينفذ على
اكياس تحديدا لانه بلا روسيا قريبه جدا من
العاصمه كاف وكان هناك ربما خطه
لهجوم جديد عليها
يعني للدخول لدخول بيلاروسيا الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا واختي حامل قوات الروسيه من خلال
بيلاروسيا الى كيف لا يحتاج جهاز الوفد
الحكومي الشامل الذي ذهب الى هناك اجتماع
البارحه في بيلاروسيا كان من اجل توطيد
علاقه دوله الاتحاد بين روسيا وبيلاروسيا
والدفاع المشترك والى اخره من هذه النقاط
واهم ما في هذه الزياره هو التلميح بان
روسيا قد تزوج طائرات
البيلاروسيه باسلحه نوويه ردا على
التهديدات التي تتعرض لها من قبلنا واضيف
الى ذلك النبيله روسيا وروسيا بما ان بلا
روسيا الحدود الغربيه لروسيا مع الناتو
يستشعرهم بالخطر الذي يعني همم موجود في
اوروبا الشرقيه وفي بولندا تحديدا وهو
300,000 مقابل انتشار سريع للناردوهم
350,000 ل 400,000 مقاتل همم انتشار عادي
وقد يكون هناك 400,000 احتياط مما يعني ان
الناتو قد حشد مليون مقاتل على الحدود
الغربيه للاتحاد الروسي بلا روسي هذا يعني
ان ذهاب بوتين الى هناك مع وفد حكومي بشكل
رسمي متكامل يضمن وزير الدفاعي ووزير
خارجته وغيرهم يعني اشاره واضحه
لبيلاروسيا ان روسيا ملتزمه بالدفاع عن
الدوله الحنيفه الشريفه في دوله الاتحاد
الروسي البيلاروسيا
البيت الابيض
مع ايراننا وقال منسقه لاتصالات بالبيت
الابيض جون كيربي للعربيه انه لا تقدم
حاليا في احياء الاتفاق النووي مع ايران
ولا توقعات بتقدم من قريب واكد كير بي ان
العوده للاتفاق النووي ليست محطه تركيز
واشنطن في الوقت الراهن هذه التصريحات
جاءت بعد ان دعا وزير الخارجيه الايراني
حسين امير عبد الله
الغربيه الى تبني منهج بناء لاحياء
الاتفاق النوويه
[موسيقى]
قلى قائد قوه المهمه السيبرانيه الوطنيه
للقياده الالكترونيه الامريكيه الجنرال
ويليام هارتمان ان الاضطرابات الداخليه في
ايران وحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ربما شطه
انتباه طهران وموسكو عن بدل المزيد من
الجهود للتاثير او التدخل في الانتخابات
النصفيه لعام 2022
واضاف الجنرال الامريكي الرفيع انه فوجئ
بالنقص النسبيه في نشاط الروس والايرانيين
خلال انتخابات التجديد النصفي
اكيد انا لما نشراته العربيه امر وزير
التعليم العالي في حكومه طالبان
بافغانستان باغلاق الجامعات امام الفتيات
وحمل القرار الذي حصلت العربيه على نسخه
منه توقيعه وزير التعليم العالي لدى محمد
نديمه وامرت الوزاره بحسب القرار جميع
الجامعات الحكوميه والخاصه بوقف تعليم
الطالبات حتى اشعار اخر جاء ذلك بعد سلسله
قرارات الممثله حيث تم منع الفتيات في
افغانستان من دخول المتنزهات وصلات
الرياضه والملاهي
ادانا الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا قرار
حكومه طالبان في افغانستان بحظر دخول
الفتيات الى الجامعات ومنع التعليمهن
واكدت الولايات المتحده انه لا يمكن ان
تتوقع طالبان قبولها في المجتمع الدولي
بتزامني مع ممارسات تنتهي حقوق الانسان
وخاصه ضد الفتيات والمراه
بغداد اثنين يتفقوا على دعم العراق يؤكد
انه لا يمكن ان يكون العراق ساحه للصراعات
بالوكالات تابعونا بعض
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد قاده الدول العربيه
خلال انطلاق اعمال مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون
والشراكه في دوره الثانيه على ان المنطقه
بحاجه الى الاستقرار والسلام العادل
والشامل واقال العاهل الاردني الملك عبد
الله الثاني ان امن العراق ركن اساسيون في
امن المنطقه فيما اوضح رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد الشيعه السوداني رغبه بغداد
في ارساء وتعزيز الشراكه الاقليميه
والدوليه واستتباب الامناء بينما عبر وزير
الخارج السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان عن
ترحيب المملكه استعاده العراق لدوره
الاقليمي والدولي ورفض اي اعتداء على اي
شبر من ارض العراق
كما تؤكد المملكه وقوفها جنب الى جنب مع
العراق
وترجمتها
تحقق نتائج
العراق الاقتصاديه والتنمويه
التام لاننا مائها ورخائها
يرتباطا وثيقا بنبات
ورخاء جيرانها منطقه يا جماعه
وجدد الرئيس الفرنسي
دعم بلاده للعراق مرددا بالتاثيرات
الخارجيه التي يتعرض لها داعيا في الوقت
نفسه الدول المشاركه في القمه الى
المساعده في تعزيز امن العراق والمنطقه
وامنه وسيادته ورخاء شعبه العراق اليوم
في قاعه واحده كل الدول والامم التي
يمكنها ان تساهم في تعزيز السياده العراق
وبالتالي استقراره وامن المنطقه
يعني هذا المؤتمر اتى اساسا بمبادره من
الرئيس الفرنسي العام الماضي في بغداد ما
الذي تريده باريس من هذا المؤتمر ما
احداثها
نعم مؤتمر الشراكه والتعاون هذا الذي هو
امتداد كما ذكرت لمؤتمر بغداد الذي كان
انعقد في الثامن والعشرين من اغسطس اب من
العام الماضي هدفه مناقشه الازمات التي
تهز المنطقه كما تقول مصادر الدبلوماسيه
فرنسيه هدف فرنسا من عقد هكذا مؤتمرات
والمشاركه في تراسها ليس فقط دعوه الدول
المشاركه فيها من بين دول الفاعله في
المنطقه الى خفض التوترات وانما ايضا الى
احلال التعاون بدل المواجهه كان لافتا ما
قاله الرئيس الفرنسي اليوم ملمحا الى
ايران دون ان يسميها عندما دعا العراق الى
السلوك مسار اخر بعيد عن
الهيمنه وبعيد عن نموذج من الخارج في
اشاره بالكاد تكون مبطنه الى ايران من دون
تسميتها قال الرئيس الفرنسي ايضا وهذا كان
لافتا ان هذه المنطقه لديها كل تلزم لتنجح
اجندتها الاقليميه والدوليه ولكن علينا ان
نعمل بشكل جماعي لتجاوز انقسامات اللحظه
فرنسا عملت دائما الطواله كل تاريخها
وعملها الدبلوماسيه على استقرار المنطقه
العراق اليوم هو احد ابرز ضحايا ال- عدم
الاستقرار الاقليمي كما قال الرئيس
الفرنسي ان المطلوب اليوم التعاون مشددا
على ضروره دعم العراق ايضا في مواجهتي
الارهاب فرنسا تدعمه ايضا لناحيه دعم
عمليته السياسيه والتنميه والاعمار في هذا
البلد
كان هناك او حصل الان تغير بالدور الفرنسي
والعلاقه مع ايران كانت العلاقه همم دور
وسيط الان هناك توتر يصل الى حد الاختلاف
السياسي الجذري بين الطهران وباريس ما
اسبابه باختصار لو سمحت
ما تذكرين هو يعكسه تصريح وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كاترين كولونات من عمان اليوم
بعد لقائها بنظيرها الايراني حسين امير
عبد الاهيان عندما قالت التقيت به لفتره
وجيزه في قاعه المؤتمر ودعوته مره اخرى
الى الافراج عن الفرنسيين المحتجزين لدى
ايران دعوته ايضا الى التزام ايران
بالقانون الدولي الانساني وبالقانون
الدولي بشكل عام التصريح لا يشير كما كان
يحصل سابقا الى التعاون بين البلدين
لمعالجه الازمات الاقليميه السبب ذلك يعود
الى اربعه عوامل اذكرها سريعا اولا ما
تعتبره فرنسا دورا ايرانيا مزعزعا
للاستقرار في المنطقه الثانيه ما تعتبره
باريس رفضا ايرانيا للتعاون من اجل اغلاق
ملف المسائل العالقه فيما يتعلق بالجانب
النووي تحديدا ما كانت ذكرته باريس عنده
ظهور اثار لليورانيوم كما تقول الوكاله
الدوليه الطاقه الذريه في ثلاثه مواقع
ايرانيه غير مصرح عنها على ايران ان تكشف
عن المواد النوويه او التجهيزات
تسببت في ظهور هذه الاثار ثالثا ضروره
افراج ايران عن الفرنسيين السبعه
الموقوفين لديها واخيرا وقف ايران ما
تسميه باريس قمعها الوحشي للمتظاهرين
قمعها لرجال ونساء يطالبون بحريتهم
واحترام حقوقهم تقول الخارجيه الفرنسيه
وقصر الرئاسه هنا ايضا راويه شكرا جزيلا
لك حسين قنيبر
[موسيقى]
رئيس الفرنسي على ان من طاقه الشرق الاوسط
تعاني من التدخلات الخارجيه والتي تسببت
في زعزعه استقرار دول عديده من بين العراق
تقرير
اليوم
العراق وقياسا بما تعرض له خلال العقود
الماضيه كان من اول ضحايا زعزعه الاستقرار
لكنني اؤكد ان هذه المنطقه تمتلك كل ما
تحتاجه لكي تذهب ابعد في المشاركه في
الاجنده العالميه لكن يتعين علينا
التي نراها
ومن باريس ينضم الينا اسامه حريري المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك سيد اسامه يعني مكروم كما
استمعنا يؤكد ان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
تحديدنا العراق يعاني من التدخلات التي
تؤثر على استقرار من يقصد بهذا الكلام
الحلقه اضعف في الكلمه التي قالها الرئيس
ماكرون يعني والتي اشار بها بطريقه واضحه
جدا صحيحه غير مباشره لكن واضحه جدا الى
الدور الايراني عندما قال سماح للعراق
للمضيف في طريقه من دون املاءات خارجيه
طبعا كان يقصد ايران والجميع يعني يعرف لا
يخفى الامر على احد ان ايران لها اليد
الطويله في العراق خاصه يعني حتى من بعد
وصول الرئيس الوزراء محمد السوداني الحالي
والذي يعد يعني مقربا من ايران مقارنه مع
رئيس الوزراء السابق القادم بالتالي يعني
كانت هناك طبعا اشاره واضحه الى الدور
الايراني هناك ايضا يعني اشاره ايضا الى
الدور التركي لان التركي يعني قامت باكثر
من مره وما زال تقوم حتى اليوم بقصف مواقع
للجماعات الكرديه ان كان في شمال سوريا او
حتى في منطقه كردستان العراق وهذا امر
يعني يندد به الخارجيه الفرنسيه اكثر من
مره مع القول دائما انها تتفهم طبعا
الضرورات الامنيه او حق تركيا بال عن
نفسها بالتالي بشكل رئيسي يعني كما قلنا
ايران هي ال- المسؤول الاول بحسب يعني
الفرنسيين او همم ماكرون عن زعزعه
الاستقرار في العراق من خلال يعني
الميليشيات المسلحه التي تدعمها من الحشد
الشعبي الى حزب الله العراقي ابقى معي سيد
اسامه لنستمع لما قاله وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد الله
ان الحباره بالتعاون بين دول الاقليم
للوصول الى فحم مشترك من اجل تحقيق
الاستقرار
والسلام
والتنميه ليس خيارا
ضروره ملحه
ان انا نعتبر استقرار بلادنا وبمنها
يرتبطان باستقرار بامن المنطقه باسرحه
اذن سيد اسامه سمعنا لما قاله الوزير عبد
اللهيان تحقيق السلام والتعاون يعني كيف
يمكن تحقيق السلام والتعاون بين دول
المنطقه وايران تدعم
الميليشيات واذرعها ان كان في اليمن وان
كان في سوريا والكان في لبنان وكان في
العراق من يضمن هذا التعاون
يعني هذا خطاب دبلوماسي بعد خطاب طبعا
نظري يتناقض كليا مع الواقع وقع ما يحدث
على الارض لانها يعني ما تقوم به ايران
يعني هو عبر استخدام يعني نفوذها في
المنطقه تقوم طبعا من اجل مصالحها القوميه
يتناقض كليا مع تصريحات عبد اللهيان التي
دعا فيها الى الحوار ومن هنا اريد ان اشير
الى نقطه مهمه بخصوص هذا المؤتمر الذي تعد
طموحاته كبيره جدا يعني اا
تناقضا مع مفاعله التي لا اعتقد انها
ستكون مفاعيل كبيره جدا لان الازمات معقده
جدا همم لكي يتم حلها في قمه واحده حتى
ولو تم الاتفاق على مؤتمر اخر سيتم عبده
في القاهره بالتالي يعني كل هذه المسائل
همم الرئيس الفرنسي يعني كان هناك حتى
حديث قبل حدوث المؤتمر عن محاوله تقريب
بين السعوديين والايرانيين من خلال حتى تم
الحديث عن لقاء مؤتمر ربما بين الرئيس ولي
العهد السعودي ولكن هذا اللقاء طبعا لم
يحدث حتى على همم مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
طبعا نفقه المعلومات الاخيره كان هناك
ايضا حديث عن نوع من النقاشات التي ستدور
بشان الملف النووي الايراني طبعا حدثت
لقاءات بين بريل وعبد اللهيان بحضور ايضا
باقري وبحضور همم الريكيمورا ولكن لم نظهر
لم لم نشهد فعلا حال حاله في هذه الملفات
وهو ايضا يعني يتناقد مع تصريح عبد الله
الذي قال انه يعني متمسك بالحوار شكرا
جزيلا لك من باريس
[موسيقى]
خرجت مسيره احتجاجيه في شوارع مدينه رام
الله الفلسطينيه احتجاجا على وفاه الاسير
الفلسطيني ناصر ابو حميده التي قالت هيئه
شؤون الاسرى والمحررين الفلسطينيين ان
السبب فيها الاهمال الطبي المتعمده من قبل
اداره السجون الاسرائيليه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه رافقته مسيرته
احتجاج على احتجاز اسرائيل جثمان الاسير
ناصر ابو حميد الذي قضى داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه بعد معاناته مع مرض السرطان
بالمناسبه يحدث مع كل الاسره ثم بعد ذلك
اجريت له عمليه جراحيه
وتعرض لخطا طبي لدخول طبيب يعني غير مختص
في العمليه يعني
دخل ناصر في حاله غيبوبه لحوالي اسبوعين
نتيجه ايضا
اهمال طبي
ناصر البالغ من العمر 50 عاما ام ضمنها 30
سنه في السجون الاسرائيليه اخرها منذ
العام 2002 اضافه الى اشقاء اربعه يقضون
احكاما مؤبده اسرائيل لم تستجب للمطالب
الفلسطينيه والعربيه والدوليه من اجل
تسليم جثمانه الى عائلته
كل ما نريده هو ان نشيع ناصر كما يليق
وكما يجب وان ندفنه الى جانب اخي الشهيد
عبد المنعم هذا قوه مطلبنا
نحن اتصلنا مع اشقاء عرب مؤثرين سواء كان
على الجانب الاسرائيلي والتصلنا ايضا
بالجهات الامريكيه وبالاداره الامريكيه
للتدخل مباشره لتسليم جثمانه لا يعقل
اطلاقا شخص تعرض الى الاهمال الطبي هناك
اربع اخوان له اسره ما زالوا في سجون
الاحتلال يعني اقل ما يمكن بالحد الادنى
من التكريم ان يسلم الى والدته والى اخوته
اكثر من اربعه الاف فلسطينيه معتقلون في
السجون الاسرائيليه بينهما العشرات يعانون
من امراض مزمنه قد يواجهون نفس المصير
الذي لقيه ناصر
اسيرا فلسطيني
وما تزال اسرائيل تحتزجه
اليه من اليوم ناصر ابو حميد لتبقى
المطالبات الفلسطينيه بتحرير جثامين
الاسرى متواصله
على مختلف المستويات
من امامي مخيم الامعري قرب رام الله خالد
القاسم العربيه
[موسيقى]
طرح الرئيس السوداني المعزول عمر البشير
امام المحكمه اليوم روايه حول انقلاب
العام
1989 تناقض روايته السابقه التي تحدث بها
ونشرتها العربيه بشكل حصري في وثائقي
الاسرار الكبرى الذي بث في ديسمبر عام
روايه البشير اليوم جاء فيها اعلانه تحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله وحده عن انقلاب عام 89
ولم يشترك معه مدني الرئيس المعزول قال ان
الانقلاب كان مبنيا على دستور العام 65
المعدل والذي حمل القوات المسلحه مسؤوليه
حمايه البلاد مشيرا الى ان مذكره الجيش
للحكومه حينها كشفت حجم الضعف والنقص الذي
تنانيه القوات المسلحه
لكن عايز اثبت حقيقه مولانا
انه كله يا اخواننا اعضاء مجلس الثوره
الموجودين هنا
في هذه القاعه
ما كان عندهم اي دور
في التخطيط او التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره كوكب من خير الضباط
القوات المسلحه عشان يمثل وحدات وتمثيل
بعض الجهال واؤكد ايضا
انه ما في اي مدينه دخل معنا
عامل عسكري بحث
الجيش حينها في بيت الضيافه زاعما انه حين
زارهم باركوا تحركه واستلامه للسلطه عازيا
انقلابه الى الاوضاع العامه السيئه في
البلاد والتي كانت السبب الحقيقي
خلال الاعترافات التي بثتها العربيه في
وثائقيات حصريه تغنى فيها بسيطره تنظيم
الاخوان على مفاصل الدوله اي انه عمل
المنظم وليست تصرفا فرديه
الدوله
الحصريه للعربيه عن اهميه تسلوي جماعه
الاخوان للسلطه بالطريقه التي يقررونها
وكيف تتم عمليات التسلسل الهرمي والسلطويض
داخل الجامعه سرا
كبير جدا
مع الحركه الاسلاميه
لعندك انت جدا في الدماغ ان احنا ضباط
ومقرروا وتستوروا السلطه فسالنا اخوان
علشان بدي اكسر الحركه
ولما قررت نحن نقنع
دها 30 عاما من الحكم خرجت اسرار التنظيم
الاكثر سريه في العالم تنظيم الاخوان
وتحدث مسؤوله بالصوت والصوره بما راوا ان
السلطان سيدوم والسريا ستبقى في
الوثائقيات الحصريه التي بثتها العربيه
تحدث البشير ونائبه علي عثمان طه وقاده
كثر في التنظيم عن تدبيرهم انقلاب يونيو
وتمكينهم لانفسهم وحرمان الاخرين هو بطشهم
الان هي دوله المشروعه الاسلاميه التي يجب
المحافظه عليها وان تكون خياراننا وجهتنا
منصبا للمحافظه عليها وتقويتها احتفاله
المنصه الاولى التي
تزيل مشروع وتجمع
نائب الرئيس السوداني المعزول علي عثمان
طه بالصوت والصوره يشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان كانت المتحكمه والحاكم الفعلي
السوداني وان حزب المؤتمر الوطني كان مجرد
واجهه للاخوان لا اكثر اليوم
ظهر البشير بمظهر المتحدي الزاعما
مسؤوليته عن انقلاب 89 لكن ما كشفته
وثائقيات العربيه يناقد روايات البشيره
الجماعه كانت الامر الناهي في السودان
وليس الرجل وكان الانقلاب مدبرا ومخططا
بشكل وثيقه
انا هاقوله بالصوت العالي ويشاركني في هذا
معظم يا اخواننا ان لم يكن جميعهم في
اللينه انه بالمعطيات التي كانت قائمه في
89 لو عاد التاريخ القهقره وفي نفس الموقف
وسنمر بالتغيير الذي حدث في 30
من الخرطوم الدكتور عبد العظيم الحسن
المحامي والخبير القانوني اهلا بك دكتور
عبد العظيم يعني البشير يعترف بتحمليه
لمسؤوليه انقلاب عام 89 بالمقابل
بوثائقيات العربيه كل ما حكم من قبله وقبل
نائبه يؤكد بانه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
هي كانت من تتحكم بمفاصل الامور والانقلاب
حينها هذا التناقد كيف يتم تفسيره
مساء الخير عليك استاذ راويه ومساء الخير
مشاهديك
حقيقي طبعا اليوم شاهدناه
من مداولات المحكمه
هذا يجري في سياقه ما نعرفه في الفقه
القانون السوداني بالمحاكمات السياسيه
وهذه المحاكمات السياسيه ليست بجديده على
واقعنا
وبتتكشف فيها كثير من الحقائق ويكون دائما
بالذات في هذه الاوقات بعد توفر المعلومه
عبر الاعلام مرئي ومسموع همم كل الحقائق
بحيث انه المحاكمات السياسيه هي هي الشاهد
بما يستمع له المواطن همم العمل السياسي
وما اذا كان في مصداقيه في العمل السياسي
نفسه
الانقلاب بتاعتي تسعه او 80 يعني كثير من
السودانيين همم كان تابع وكله وقايعه
وشهوده هم نفسهم على من هو المتحكم همم من
نظام الاخوان المسلمين
والحاجات به نفسها ما ذكر في المحكمه
اليوم او لم يذكر او ذكر في الوثائق يعني
معروف انه حتى لما قام هذا الانقلاب انه
وين كان حتى موجودين يعني كانوا موجودين
في ضاحيه الرياض والنظام نفسه والانقلاب
نفسه كان بيديروا مثلا علي عثمان كل هذه
حقائق معلومه للمواطنه السوداني اركان
للمواطن السوداني وبالتالي اعتراف البشير
من الناحيه القانونيه والسياسيه ما
مدلولاته يعني هو اعترف انا المسؤول
قانونيا ماذا يعني ذلك
الاحتراف الصدر اليوم يعني اضطر حقائق
كثيره جدا كانت معلومه للكثيرين بانه
التنظيم عندما قام بهذا الانقلاب يعني حتى
البشير نفسه معلوم للمواطنه السوداني كان
مجرد يعني بروتوكول ما ما عنده وجود حقيقي
يعني شكل فقط لاتمام عمليه الانقلاب وهذه
الاحداث يعني شهد بها من دبر الانقلاب
نفسه يعني الوقائع حتى في كثير من الاشياء
سواء كان نشرت على عبر وثائقكم او غيره في
كثير من الحقائق كانت معلومه لكثير من
المواطنين يعني كيف حتى التنظيم امن عمليه
انتقال البشير نفسه
منزله بضاحيه كوبر حتى ما وصل المكان
نفسه كل هذه الحقائق يعني مبذوله قبل
الميديا ومعروفه الان المحاكم فيها مزيد
مزيد من المحاكمه السياسيه لانه تنظيم مثل
هذا التنظيم كيف يستطيع ان ينكر حقائق
معلومه للكافه
المحكمه هي علانيه المحاكمه لماذا هي
علانيه
واحده من المسائل المطلوبه في القانون
السوداني كل المحاكمات يجب ان تكون علانيه
يعني السريه ما بتكون الا في مسائل بتتعلق
بالشرف او مساء نفس نفسها من المسائل
المتعلقه بالعرض وكده لكن طالما هذه
الاجراءات همم امام همم يجب ان تكون
مبذوله للجمهور ليس هناك ما يحول انها
تكون متاحه للاعلام لانه في في ذلك مزيد
من همم
الاتاحه لتوضيح الحقائق وما اذا كان يعني
هذه المحاكمه زي ما وصفتها لك في بدايه
هذه الاجابه انها محاكمه سياسيه المواطن
محتاج يعرف يعني الى اي مدى كان هذا
التنظيم بيحكم وباي طريقه هل هو صعب هل هو
كاذب
نعمين شفافيه اكثر من اجل المواطنين شكرا
جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد العظيم الحسن
المحامي والخبر القانوني
وفاه شاب مصري ابتهاجا بفوز الارجنتين
بكاس العالم تابعونا بعض الفاصل
[موسيقى]
تحديات اقتصاديه جمع اربكت حسابات العالم
حادا للنمو اما الفقر خلال عام 2022 فقد
شكلت جائحه كورونا اكبر انتكاسا لجهود
الحد منه في العالم منذ عقود وبحلول نهايه
2022 يمكن ان يصل الى
685 مليون شخص في فقره ما يجعل 2022 ثاني
اسوء عام على مستوى جهود الحد من الفقر في
العقدين الماضيين بعد 2020 الازمه الاخرى
المديونيه العالميه اذا ارتفعت مستويات
الديون العامه للبلدان الناميه على مدى
العقود الماضيه اذ نحو 60% من الدول
الافقر هي في حاله مديونيه حرجه او معرضه
لتلك المخاطر الوضع ليس افضل كذلك بالنسبه
لاسعار الغذاء وانعدام الامن الغذائي
تشاهد عام 2022 ارتفاعا حادا في انعدام
الامن الغذائي في جميع انحاء العالم
واستجابه للازمه اتاحت مجموعه البنك
الدولي 30 مليار دولار للتصدي لانعدام
الامن الغذائي على مدى 15 شهرا الازمه
الاكبر هي في الطاقه شهد النصف الاول من
2022 واحده من اكبر الصدمات التي شهدها
العالم في اسواق الطاقه العالميه منذ عقود
زادت اسعار الطاقه زياده كبيره ما ادى الى
تفاقم ونقص بالطاقه وزياده التباطؤ في
حصول الجميع على مصادر طاقه حديثه ميسوره
التكلفه وموثوقه ومستدامه بحلول عام
2020 في هذا الموضوع بالذات وبعد مفاوضات
مضنيه توصل الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
للاتفاق يحدد سقف اسعار الغاز بعد مفاوضات
استمرت الشهرا حول السعر المناسب وزيره
الطاقه الملطيه مريم ديالي قالت ان
الاتفاق توصل لتحديد سقف للاسعار عند 80
يورو بدلا من 275 يورو لكل ميغاوات في
الساعه هذا بالتالي يساعد في امتصاص الغضب
المتصاعد في الشارع الاوروبي نتيجه ازمه
الطاقه الحاليه الزميل ناصر الطيبي يشرح
لنا بالتفاصيل قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي
بوضعي سقف لسعر الغاز وشروط التطبيقه
اذا المشاهدين بعد اسابيع من النقاشات
الصعبه توصلت دول الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
اتفاق حول تحديد سقفا لسعر الغاز وقد
اعترضت المجر على الاتفاق بينما تحفظت
هولندا والنمسا
نتحدث الان عن السقف السعر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي تم وضعه بعد الكثير من
المفاوضات عند مستوى ال 180 يورو للميجا
وات ساعه طبعا هذا يبدا تطبيق السقف
السعري في الخامس عشر من فبراير المقبل
عندما نتحدث عن هذا السعر نتحدث عن عقود
الشهر المقبل التي يتم تداولها في البورصه
الهولنديه تي تي اف وهي اكبر بورصه لتداول
عقود الغاز في الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا يتم
تفعيل هذا السقف السعري في
الطين اساسيين لتفعيله الشرط الاول انه
السعر لعقود الشهر المقبل في البورصه
الهولنديه تي تي اف تتجاوز ال 180 يورو
للميجا وات ساعه لمده ثلاثه ايام على
التوالي هذا الشرط الاول اما الشرط الثاني
فهو ان ايضا يكون سعر همم العقود الشهر
المقبل بعد ان تتجاوز لمده ثلاثه ايام ال
180 همم يورو يجب ان تكون اعلى من السعر
العالمي للغاز المسال ب 35 يورو للميجا
وات ساعه وسيتم اختيار مؤشر قياس همم
ليكون هو الدليل لسعر اسعار الغاز المسال
عالميا مع العلم بانه لا يوجد هناك سعر
موحد للغاز المسال في العالم اذا هذا
بالنسبه
للسقف السعر همم مع
صار بانه هذا السقف فقط يفعل على
التداولات في البورصه لا يفعل على
التداولات اوفر ذا كاونتر وليس له علاقه
بعقود توريد الغاز طويله الاجل من خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
تبقى في الرياضه وصوره اليوم للساحر ميسي
ميسي يحتضم كاس العالم على سريره ويعلق
بصوره نشرها عبر صفحته الرسميه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي صباح الخير زهره وهو
بجانب الكاس ويحتضنه
فيديو اليوم هو لعوده المنتخب الارجنتيني
الى بلاده بالكاس حيث كان في استقباله
الالاف من المشجعينه شهدت العاصمه
الارجنتينيه احتفالات مستمره منذ الفوز
للدراميه على فرنسا في المباراه النهائيه
يوم الاحد الماضي حيث قدرت وسائل الاعلام
ارجنتينيه عدد المحتفلين بالعاصمه بلس
ايرس بالاربعه ملايين شخص
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اجواء الفرح هذه هنا انتقل الى الزميل
عادل عيدان وملفات اخبار الساعه مساء
الخير ياعسل مساء النور
زيارتان بين بوتين وزنسكي هي حربوزيرات
والرسائل المتابادله تفضل
[موسيقى]